josh is with us josh is in ohio hi Josh
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show mr. ng
how you don't better than I deserve
what's up hey I got a couple questions
for you I got people telling me that I
should claim bankruptcy chapter 7 I'm 32
years old currently making thirty-nine
thousand a year I'm about 14,000 in
collections those youngin bellman didn't
pay nothing
I also have nine thousand dollars of
school loans and $6,300 auto loan so
then about collections is about 24
different looks like here in front of me
like 24 different people I just started
listening to you probably two weeks ago
okay so I'm kind of gay I guess your
input on it should I go ahead with the
bankruptcy or should I try to take
myself out of it because I've really
been thinking about money lately and I'm
tired of a paycheck paycheck
I'm a single father just got custody of
my daughter mmm hold your baby she's 10
years old
okay cool well a guy told me one time
when I was broke and I was digging out
of the bottom I was in my 20s
he said debt is not the problem it is
the symptom of other problems other
words debt is the result of other things
going on in my case it was overspending
disorganized impulsive just not paying
attention you know that kind of stuff
which some of that's probably you isn't
it yep well the good news is all of
those things are choices and so
instantaneously right now you can just
decide okay now I'm organized I'm not
gonna live disorganized anymore you can
just decide now I'm not spending any
money
except on a plan because I want to
straighten this freaking mess up because
I'm tired of the constant stress of
living paycheck to paycheck I feel like
a rat in a wheel and I'm gonna do what
it takes to never be there again you can
just decide that regardless of whether
you file bankruptcy or not by the way
you need to decide that don't you know
you know so the only question is whether
you pay the debt offer whether you
bankrupt it because you've got to do
those other things anyway or you're just
gonna always be like this
agreed okay cool
and so you're ready man I mean you're
ready to do what it takes so here's what
I want to do we have a class that's nine
weeks long called Financial Peace
University where we will teach you what
you should have been taught in high
school on how to handle money how to get
on a budget how to work systematically
through these debts and get rid of them
because dude if you had zero payments
and you had a plan for every dollar
you'd have a pretty good life yeah yeah
and so wait that's where we need to get
you to and it starts with having a plan
for every dollar and then working our
way through these debts
now the sixty three hundred dollar car
loan is current the nine thousand dollar
student loan is it current I kept
deferring it okay so it's it is not
bankrupt able by the way it's gonna be
there after the bankruptcy if you file
bankruptcy so is the car debt you're
still going to have the card debt or
you're going to give up the car one of
the two and your car is not really out
of control
it's not like crazy land okay it's a
decently pr's ridiculous it's like 18
percent oh okay good there's good one to
get rid of there yeah and then you got
$14,000 in collections and you're not
paying on those anyway right now no okay
and you're not even paying on the
student loan right now no just a car
right so how much do you bring home
bring home a week is about 580 okay and
how big was your tax refund I haven't
followed it yet
how big was it last year last year they
ended up taking it like I didn't get
anything
oh yeah they're gonna tell you it again
okay yeah do you remember how much it
was that they took I want to say it was
like only $700 okay all right well
that's $700 too much coming out of your
check a year that's where that comes
from they over withheld and so you may
you do need to go down and recalculate
your withholding and raise your
take-home pay about $50 a month at least
a month Oh 15 $20 a check
that'll help okay are you putting any
money into retirement today no I stopped
that good do you have any money going
into anything at work no I'm not
currently now good okay and so you're
making about 600 bucks a week and so
you're making about 2,400 bucks
take-home pay how much is your rent will
mean my girlfriend split it so out of
mine it's about 600 a month okay okay
and where does the okay if we take 2,400
home and you put $600 on rent where's
the rest of your money go Oh stupid
spending honestly no I mean really you
need to buy food you need buy food you
gotta buy lights and water right yeah
and then how much your car payment about
three oh seven okay there's part of it
right so that's how a budget is done you
just start to lay it out like that where
every dollar has an assignment so here's
what I would do let's adjust your w-4
and get your take-home pay up slightly
50 to 100 bucks a month extra coming
home okay and that'll help a little bit
I'm gonna put you into Financial Peace
University our non week class I'm gonna
pay for it doesn't cost you you're
awesome okay but you got to go to the
class and you got to go turn your life
around that's mandatory okay yes sir all
right and then what we're gonna do
you're not paying on the collections
right now and you're not paying the
student loan right now so what I want
you to do is I want you to squeeze every
dollar out of your life and I want you
to work an extra job or overtime and
squeeze every dollar out of your life I
want you to squeeze every dollar out of
your life you're not allowed to go out
to eat you don't see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
you've got to clean this mess up you're
not going on vacation
you have no need to be sitting on your
butt watching TV at any point you have
work to do okay game on baby
game on alright you can do this now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna pay
stinking car off in 20 minutes here
alright listen here's the deal you know
six thousand three hundred bucks and you
got twenty four hundred bucks coming
home hey I want you to pay fifteen
hundred to two thousand dollars a month
on this car on with this car paid off in
four months
okay but that's beans and rice rice and
beans at home no frills no lies I don't
care if she likes it she buried to a
broke guy she'll like a guy that's good
decide he's gonna stand up and be
somebody well if she doesn't like it she
ain't for you you need to be somebody
man it's time to do this it's your butt
on fire let's get in gear you got this
man
you can do this hey you're gonna knock
his car you had no car payment would
that give you a little confidence after
you knock that thing out three or four
months from now dadgum right it would ya
and then we're going to line up those 14
thousand dollars at collections and
we're going to call the first one and
we're gonna get a deal on that you're
probably going to settle those by
somewhere around 25 30 cents on the
dollar so somewhere around four or five
six thousand bucks more it's gonna clear
them off so by Christmas you could have
everything paid off except your student
loan and by the time I talked to you
this time next year everything is gone
you're gonna be debt-free and just a
brat right around a year but you're
gonna it's gonna be the worst year of
your life in the best year of your life
you're gonna do nothing but work and pay
bills but you ain't doing nothing but
working and paying bills now and you're
doing it in such a screwed-up way that
it ending in working mmm so might as
well get somewhere might as well have a
little traction am I missing something
here no no no all right coach you got
this man I'm gonna be with you we're
gonna put you in the nine week class and
the one year membership and you guys
line it up and you can start showing
that ten-year-old that are that they're
that daddy is changing his life right
now daddy's getting ready to beat
somebody this is getting ready to change
it's gone on long enough
this this dull pain that is your life
it's time to shift it into gear you got
this man
I'm so proud of you
I'm proud of where you're gonna be this
time next year you're rocking this you
call me if you need help okay
I'm right here man I got you but you
better get after it cuz I'm gonna put a
foot in your butt if you don't let's go
man